[Music]
like simple you know I'll even design
certain like certain characters like on
Rick and Morty I designed a mr. poopy
butthole and a noob noob
we gotta keep an eye out for any zany
wacky characters that pop up we're here
to help
thanks mr. poopy butthole I always could
count on you you can tell they're like
mind you you know they look the same
almost you know I just like that kind of
simple look Morty you gotta turn into a
car what a long time ago I implanted you
with the subdermal chip that can call
upon dormant nanobots in your
bloodstream to restructure your Anatomy
and turn you into a car my god
concentrate Morty concentrate turn into
a car Morty
never mind here's the taxi get it it's
fine you don't need to know how it works
you know you just need to know what it
does and you sort of understand there's
there's sci-fi you know hand-waving
there's sci-fi stuff going on to make it
work I find that the more you think
about that stuff and try to figure it
out you're doing yourself a disservice
to your schedule and you know what I
mean like you start to spiral who cares
about the thing you guys are talking
about the whole point of freezing time
was to stop giving a I know when Rick
and Morty we had the time that time free
where they unfreeze time and then
they're sort of they're in trouble
because of it like the time starts
splitting you want me to get Intel out
of the smartest mammal in the galaxy you
better give me a decent brain Eliezer
and then the top of season three with
the brain Eliezer that was another one
it's like how does a brain Eliezer work
you know thinking way too much about
that when ultimately it's like we don't
need to know how it works
we just need to visually make sure that
it's clear what's happening so the
audience is completely following along
you know but we don't need to know how
these machines work you know in order to
tell that story yeah I'd like to get a
ten-piece McNugget and a bunch of the
Szechuan sauce like as much as you're
allowed to give me that thing was just a
throw away and then to see it turn into
what it did it's chaos how to McDonald's
over of all things Szechuan sauce I mean
I think it was a little sobering like oh
my god the show
was really getting big but I don't think
that would change our process and what
we want to do at all I mean we can't
worry about that stuff you know it's
like our our fan base is humanity you
know
so we're there's a lot of bad [ __ ] going
on out there so and a lot of good stuff
not not glass half-empty but because the
world is full of idiots that don't
understand what's important and they'll
tear us apart Morty but if you stick
with me I'm gonna accomplish great
things Morty I think he's a deeply
flawed character you know I mean that's
sort of the point when we're working
with that character it's like you know
he's he's got a lot of dark [ __ ] under
the under the surface
he's also fun and crazy you know there
there are fun things about him but we're
certainly not writing him to be a role
model by any you know stretch of the
imagination no I mean when we're writing
that show we're very much thinking about
what's a great fun entertaining story we
can tell there's no other motivation
other than we just want the show to be
good we want to stay ahead of the
audience and we want to make sure that
you can't sit and predict what's gonna
happen next like the goal is to always
stay ahead of the audience as much as
possible hey everybody rejoice they just
started working on Rick and Morty season
four we got our official start date all
the writers were like yes I can't
confirm we did start working on season
four so that's why you see people like
Justin roiland doing interviews he was
at e3 this past weekend promoting his
new trover saves the universe game of
course everywhere he goes people asked
him about Rick and Morty so that's why
we get all that cool interview stuff he
also gave some separate quotes that give
you an idea for what their timeline is
especially going into future seasons
after season four so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe for
more Rick and Morty there's actually a
season three blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this but here's his other quote that
he gave so I'm just gonna read what he
said we're super excited that for the
first time ever we're locked in we know
what the future is we have job security
that was them locking down that 70
episode order so the network won't fire
them while the
working on that harmon is in great
spirits we have a great writers room we
want the episodes to stay good but we
also do want to try and turn them around
a little quicker now that we have this
big order I think it gives us the
ability to be faster we're not gonna do
these long breaks these chasms in
between seasons anymore we're gonna
schedule vacation time and just keep the
Machine going it's going to be really
cool
it's know Rick and Morty forever 100
years Rick and Morty Rick and Morty calm
but it does seem a little more
sustainable as a work-life balance
strategy at least that last little bit
isn't him saying that Rick and Morty
will end after they do this 70 episode
order it just means that they have a big
order they're gonna fulfill and then
we'll see what happens after that but if
you're not a big animation geek or you
haven't been following the animation
production industry for a long time a
lot of times what will happen is is when
a show gets a big big episode order like
this they'll have their animation
studios and all the writers the people
that work on the show they'll work on
that continuously without taking really
big hiatuses until they finish whatever
their episode order is in the case of
Rick and Morty that's 70 episodes so
whereas a normal hiatus might be six
weeks to a couple months what Justin
Rowand is implying that they're gonna do
is just have smaller vacations that they
pre schedule per mandated Union rules
there are unions that tell you how much
you can make your employees work so
there is like a bare minimum you can't
run it like a sweatshop but that just
means they'll spend more time on task
more time riding episodes and they've
also talked about refining their process
for getting episodes to animation Dan
Harmon's been really critical of himself
in the past in the way that he tried to
do Rick and Morty the way you would do a
live-action series and what happens in
animation is is that you actually need
to get episodes to animators as fast as
possible because the animation process
is what takes the longest sometimes it
can take up to six months to animate an
episode but you might be able to write
an episode in like six weeks so the
faster you get it to animators the
faster you can get the season out what
they used to do like you would do on a
live-action television series is they
would just rework scripts until they
were perfect then sent episodes off to
animation so it would take a little bit
longer to get them to animation now
they've learned one of the tricks of
animation
is that you can actually change the
dialogue that you give characters quite
a bit after the episode has been
animated so it's just much easier to get
those episodes to the animators which is
also contributing to them getting
seasons out faster everybody's wondering
when are they gonna drop season 4 you
know big white Santa Claus beard are
they gonna get it out before Christmas
next year if they can get all the
episodes into animation by the end of
the year just get it started being
animated by the end of the year then
they can totally hit a 2019 release date
but it would either be late summer by
the end of the year but depending on how
quickly they get that going they could
totally get it out by next summer but
I'm just not gonna hold my breath for
that I'm just gonna assume unless we
hear there's some huge delay or some big
problem in a couple months like oh it's
gonna take us way longer I'm gonna
assume big white Santa Claus beard will
see episodes at least by November or
December but a lot of that will just
depend on how the work goes in the
writers room in the next couple of
months so I'm sure they'll be posting
behind the scenes if we get any updates
I will totally post videos obviously
Comic Con is coming up I'm expecting
them to go and just talk about what's
going on with season four and some of
the ideas that they have maybe they'll
have an early animatic because there's a
lot of ideas that they had to cut out
from previous seasons that they might
just start off season four with like oh
that episode that we were gonna do
because we only did 10 episodes instead
of 14 now we can do that during season 4
there's also the non-canonical stuff
like the transcript that they posted a
couple years ago which was totally
hilarious but obviously not part of the
actual season let me tell you how this
is gonna work you're gonna tell me [ __ ]
listen suck my shut up listen to me like
my man listen
suck my don't be here in the court on
money here sucking my listen to me now
you're so okay so let me know in the
comments what do you think about all
this leave all your bonus video requests
in the comments below
congratulations to miles Parker you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for more
Season four videos and click here for
brand new Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]